monday night football game last night
kind of stunk you just heard the coaches
talking about it right there afterwards
new orleans leave town with the win i've
never heard so many atmospheric river
bomb typhoon every term in the books
being thrown around but that was the
story of both prime time games weather
mess these quarterbacks what do you see
on monday night football
well sean payton talked about the
weather he talked about field position
and making sure you know you take care
of the football and he came out with a
pretty conservative approach which i'm
not mad at him because he didn't want
jameis winston to mess the game up so
jameis was more like a game manager and
the guy that i had my eye on definitely
i mean alvin kamara had a huge game but
on the defensive side of the ball
demario davis was outstanding and i just
love hearing him talk after the game
about hey you're not going to run on us
i'm and he was all over the field making
plays in the backfield and just showed
that natural leadership but they could
not run the ball seattle could not run a
ball against new orleans
he's one of the best free agency pickups
that i've seen since maybe in new
orleans maybe since drew brees who's
been a better free agency pickup that
they've had there and he's sort of
floated under the radar too you know no
not enough people talking about what
demario davis has brought to that saints
defense and i just don't know that i'm a
believer and i don't want to go crazy
after a rain game i think after a bad
weather game like we were in san
francisco we saw how rough those
conditions were it looks similar in
seattle so i don't want to come down too
hard on geno come down too hard on
jameis winston after last night but i
didn't think either quarterback was
impressive in any way shape or form i
just thought it was some ugly ugly
football
and i don't think it was just all
because of the weather they didn't
really seem to have confidence or know
where they were going with the football
and they were letting pressure get their
way too easy i just thought it was poor
sloppy quarterback play and i am going
to give them a little asterisk with
horrible weather
i look at a guy like geno smith who's
been a backup for a long long time and
the last couple weeks since russell
wilson has been out you've been given an
opportunity to be the starting
quarterback and that's all a backup
quarterback wants is an opportunity
especially when you're playing behind
guys like aaron rodgers uh russell
tom brady these guys matt ryan these
guys don't get hurt so anytime you get
an opportunity to show your level of
talent and what you can do on a football
field you have to take advantage of it
and if i got dk metcalf and i got tyler
lockett and and i have those weapons i'm
throwing the ball down the field it's
and i just i felt like geno he act like
he was afraid to throw the ball down the
field when you have that level of talent
and just throw the ball up and let him
go get it
yeah how about the play to dk metcalf
that was one of the more awesome plays
of that game really probably the only
awesome play of that game where he's
running down the sideline he and
lattimore have some hand fighting going
on as they're running and then dk gets
the best from sort of knocking his hand
down off of him people calling for
offensive pass interference on this play
you'll watch him right at the top of the
screen i don't think so both parties
pretty guilty but dk's ability to out
physical these big talented cornerbacks
and then that speed i mean somebody with
that much size should not be able to hit
that gear it's like derek henry those
guys that much power that much size that
much skill should not be able to do that
at the end of the play when he starts
raising those knees man that looks like
an olympic sprinter or something running
down the sideline doesn't it
i just have i would like to see that
play again if we can because watch watch
watch dk metcalf and watch him push and
of course he shouldn't be punished
because he's 230 pounds but just watch
him create separation this is a good jam
by marshawn right at that end that's
when he takes him and he just kind of
push him down and that's an offensive
pass interference anytime you're a
defensive back and you're defending a
wide receiver if you grab him if you
touch him after five yards they grab now
watch his left arm
look at that he took his left arm and he
threw him down that's a technique that
that's something that he's been
practicing in the offseason that's
something that
one of his trainers showed him because
he took him by the arm he slung him down
he's 230 pounds and he bullied him that
should have been a past interference
offensively
that is spoken like a true db right
there that is spoken like a true
defensive back because i'll tell you
what i saw i saw lattimore hooking him
trying to grab him with that arm he's
putting that arm it's hand fighting on
all those go routes right you always got
the hand fighting lattimore is trying to
hook him lattimore was grabbing him the
whole time and dk finally said take a
little bit of this 250 pounds or
whatever the heck he is wow ball game
that's just what dk metcalf does but
there's there's not many guys like even
even when you see him go up against
jalen ramsey
not many dbs can help physical dk
metcalf even the biggest ones
nobody can nobody can you got to be
smart when you're playing against a guy
like that but i you know what marshawn
lattimore showed a lot of toughness and
i don't care and dk matt kav probably
should notice after he played i'm like
marshawn would not back down from anyone
i don't care how big how fast how strong
you are that's one of the most
competitive players in the national
football league and that's why the
saints gave him over 90 million on his
contract because this guy dk metcalf
when we saw him on the field in
pittsburgh i could not believe that they
actually make human beings like that i
mean 63 230 pounds and he looks angry he
looks mad and then when he runs he runs
like a deer so how do you defend a guy
like that do you play him on do you
press him because if you press him then
you get too close he just pushes you and
then you fall to the ground do you play
off of him
i mean what do you do to a guy like that
he's just so big and so explosive
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports